all right well hello alicia and mark
hi keisha how are you good you guys look
great
i'm excited to talk to you guys so thank
you
uh so the babysitter's club new tv
series on netflix premiering july 3rd
it's a reboot of the beloved franchise
uh first alicia
as a mother yourself what did you bring
from your real life to the role
well i am a single mother
[Laughter]
i understand the difficulty of
managing so much on your plate just
the exhaustion and overwhelm and
um you know just and i think in liz's
case she's um she's got four kids
yes four of them and she's
not have she doesn't have any help i
mean she
she except they are older now which is
helpful but one of them's little he's a
little squash
monkey that little boy and um so
they're you know i think it's a lot to
manage
i don't think she's i don't think she's
even she's a good mom but she's not like
we're different moms i think she's like
just trying to keep it together just
trying to keep them alive and in the
house
and not dead really that's that's kind
of what i think she's which which by the
way
you know is important it's important
it's important i don't know that she's
able to take it to the next level yet
but she does with christy and that's
what's really lovely this relationship
between her and christy she's able to
really get into some
good juicy psychological stuff with her
and um
and i think she is a good mother i'm
just teasing because she's actually
but i think her main thing is just keep
keep them alive and
um try to make some money to survive
kind of thing you know
um did either of you ever babysit before
when you were younger
and were you good at it i never babysat
no one trusted me with their children i
don't know why
i was a very good boy uh but i had
babysitters that i loved and i
i had a night which i recently shared
where i was gonna run away from home and
my babysitter
really saved my life if i'm thinking
about it because he put
his hand on my forehead as i stood with
my suitcase
ready to walk out the door and kept me
from running away
and who knows what might have happened
so yeah babysitters are important you're
entrusting them with your children
i'm envisioning a baby rhino because i
was in africa one time and there was a
baby rhino that was
being you know rehabilitated and they
like to play by pushing on the head
pushing you on the head like this i
think my babysitter had studied rhinos
prior to
that night um
alicia did you uh babysit it all before
i
did before clueless i babysat a ton and
i was
really into babysitting and i would
never allow
a babysitter my age to babysit my son
are you
crazy people but um but were you a good
babysitter
it was a very good babysitter i don't
know i thought
i mean i don't know you know that but
not the kind that i would want for my
kids you see what i mean
i was i was like young
i mean 9 10. oh my god
i think i mean it was different it's
different times guys
but um but i remember kids like drawing
on the wall and i was
just i don't know how to make them stop
what am i supposed to do other than
telling them to stop and i remember a
little boy that i babysat
that i loved so much he was um i babysat
him and his
sister and he he would every time i tell
him you know it's time for bed he would
start to cry
and what holding him and
nurturing him so that he could feel good
again
was so amazing to me that feeling
i was in love with this little boy he
was just you know and then i would
make him try to make him feel better and
that i felt i love i wanted to be a
mother when i was like two my mom
i used to go around saying my baby all
the babies so i definitely have that
instinct
of wanting that so it was fulfilled and
i didn't really enjoy it but
i wouldn't trust a a little kid to stay
at home
with another little kid at this that's
my personal choice but i think it was
different times we were in a really
small it wasn't a big town that we lived
in so
relatively safe well you know what my my
daughter's 14 in
in a week and she babysits for the
younger two
who are 12 and 10 all the time and
she also gets hired by neighbors and and
she goes and she prepares and she
brings all of her crafts and games
she takes it very seriously they're not
going to be on screens
she's going to teach them something and
play with them in a way that's
like human beings interacting instead of
screams
and so she's a good babysitter and
sounds like a great babysitter
yeah i'd like her to be a member of the
babysitter's club season two i don't
know the only thing i really wanted was
to eat their food
and like hang out and watch tv i was not
so you stole a lot of food from the
houses that you babies in
nice i would do the dishes too but i
really enjoyed uh the eating part
well thank you guys so much it was so
lovely talking to both of you and the
show is great
thank you so much thank you bye guys
you